Hillary Clinton has met some of the most
famous entertainers and politicians in
the world but there's one celebrity who
still leaves the presidential candidate
in awe ET caught up with Clinton and her
daughter Chelsea on the campaign trail
Wednesday morning a lot of stars of step
for it to speak up for you to hold
fundraisers to raise money is there
anyone who still gets you starstruck oh
my gosh with George Clooney and Amal did
that event for me at their home I was
starstruck I mean obviously I'm a huge
fan of George's and I hadn't yet met
Imam but I knew people who knew her
because she is a human rights lawyer
which I am enthusiastically impressed by
so the idea that they were gonna do this
and then we got to spend some personal
time together that that was pretty
starstruck eat I'm good we couldn't
agree more but Chelsea has her own
favorite Hollywood moment when Katy
Perry performed for my mom and just
seeing all of the girls in the audience
who were so inspired by my mom and by
Katy standing there together
I was pretty starstruck by that moment